both teams with three in the third last game
to get closer than the game was Montreal lost
at home to Tampa Detroit lost at Madison Square
Garden in comes Ras M who stops Pearson on him
to the line to Petri and a save made and held
by Primo taken down Petri forced Gallagher to
the ice Monahan played one back to the line for
gouie 7 and 1 12 years in Montreal then played
61 games with the Penguins and now with the Red
Wings shot right off the draw and they do take a
lot of penalties the Canadians second most in
the league 53 times they've been short-handed
will they be for a 54th we'll see what Detroit
does here the goal nearly were L and let it
go well Lin's been shooting the
puck two for holding 46 shots on
goal gets it back from Raymond now
to cider and a save made by Primo
cider again Walman firing one and
he's got a terrific shot we've seen
that kept in by cop mve back here pet Tre F
the shot Pon stopped there by Primo CED to
wman quickly to a Brink it bman kept it in but
wasn't much he could do there was in his feet
then he blocked the attempt for Suzuki we go
TI brought in here by new hook and they score
wow nice play by new hook played back mat
moving in and it's one nothing and the Red
Wings have given up the first goal again for
a seven straight game cider absolutely blows
a tire first of all that puck was in the feet of
wall he couldn't handle that and he blocked it
but right here cider goes flying nobody around
him really nice play by new hook and mat with
a good Miss shot to the blocker side makes it
one to nothing but uh with a defense oh my God
cider hit a rut no shots on that power play
Petri out of the box and he's open at Center
Jeff Pet's got it M's in with him Petri a shot
into the glove of Primo for it but it was too
far for him and then a good play to get away
from zarnik closi a 19-year-old got help there
from Dvorak the veteran the shot in in and out
of the club of ryer and had to make another save
as a result of [Applause] that six giveaways
in the first period Lin carries in and front
goes off the leg and then Rond couldn't bang it
home sent one back for wman able to find it back
for did well then lost here to Suzuki he's in the
clear Suzuki and goal post wow Rymer got a piece
of it he can't be found he's hiding somewhere
check the front of the net usually Was Here
Comes Anderson driving in penalty up coming will
there be a penalty shot we'll see good be no no
the hold getting to the total last season well
the big body helped protect the puck there by
[Applause] Anderson you did grab
him on the right hip no question
about that he did get a start off he
used to be he got a chance they didn't
call him down low it goes Monahan
in for Anderson covered mat kept it
in mat with it took the shot rebound scores
Maham on the power play seven goals on
the season four with the man Advantage
for Shawn monan with goals now in five of his
past six game really upset watch cider sck oh
wow oh my goodness how do you not call that
so that's twice now Mick on the first goal
yeah and the guy that does it scores the
goal I mean you got to be kidding me red
coaches are up in arms at the bench I you got
you can't blame him like really but this is
not reviewable no but I mean holy mackel
but what's going on we do have something
going on well let's see what we've got and see
if we can see where the challenge is this has
to be all lightening fast coming from the
dressing room here it is quick decision
after coach's challenge video review it was
determined that the play was offside we have no
goal vro gain center Austin lift to the
stick allows Ras to get there right in a
goal [Music] wow perhaps fer got a piece of it
on the way through we'll have to see but rasm
made the [Music] play didn't go off fiser Fischer
drives the front of the net it might have gone off
him and into the net we don't sure but I think
it did by his reaction so nonetheless and they
might be reviewing [Applause] this he might
be reviewing this the back of his left hand
D it h his chest or the hand it may not have got
his hand well they they're already looking at it
see oh yeah but they're looking but the left
the only question is going to be [Applause]
onahan mat to Suzuki with a shooting Lane but
passed it blocked by C Suzuki again this time
shoots and scores he passed the first time it
was a mistake that time no mistake to the back
of the net and a early power play goal makes
it two to one and he hit both hands at his
sides like what am I supposed to do that angle
doesn't really tell you but what oh I see okay
so wman kept it in top with Peno and
confer yes sir coner top shelf two2
did I hear a crossbar can on that one may
have been wow severe angle too [Music] this
Puck kept alive down low right there by
valeno that's a really severe angle for
sure short side off the shoulder up under
the bar I thought I heard a funny sound
even standing here on the bench I mean
he'll take anything like that boy 2 two
game mat for Montreal the
borak and suuk mat brings
it in mat right to the goal and a save made by
Rymer back for valeno Montreal
changing oh boy stolen away from cop Suzuki
to win in overtime no couldn't beat Rymer
that time Suzuki left there for lin Lin
Wheeling around behind for to brinkin now
with some room to break it right in save made
by Primo from Point Blank Range circling is
Suzuki who has it now back to mat Coffield
there it is oh couldn't one time it now
he shoots and scores Coffield with the
overtime winner for Montreal on the power
play the Red Wings have lost two
straight Comer doesn't want to give it up he's
he's really upset himself he's a lot of a lot
of passion in this game tonight boy Comer
just not going he doesn't want to leave the
ice he's going towards the Penalty Box
right now with two referees over there
and he's giving him a piece of his mind to
about something that happened on the ice